[Musique]
bonsoir à tous Alors j'ai commencé par
me présenter comme ça vous savez à qui
vous avez à faire je m'appelle Valentine
Kaporal j'ai 36 ans et j'ai deux enfants
de 4 et 6 ans qui mettent tous les jours
mes limites à rue des preuves mais là
n'est pas le sujet du coup ce soir je
vais vous parler et je vais vous
raconter comment j'ai réussi à dépasser
mes limites et je vais vous raconter
également comment j'ai osé jeter
l'opercule de la barquette de beurre
vous verrez plus tard ça ça fera du sens
je suis quelqu'un de très scolaire donc
du coup quand on m'a donné le thème de
cette aidex on m'a dit au-delà des
limites mon premier réflexe ça a été
d'aller ouvrir un dictionnaire et de
regarder les différentes définitions du
mot limite j'en ai trouvé deux la
première c'est donc une ligne qui sépare
deux terrains contiguës et la seconde
c'est la partie extrême où se termine
une surface
et finalement quand moi je pense aux
limites et bien je me dis qu'il y a deux
types de limites celle qu'on peut
dépasser et celles qu'on ne peut pas
dépasser ou en tout cas qu'on ne doit
pas dépasser et ça ressemble finalement
à ces deux définitions les limites qu'on
ne peut pas dépasser ou qu'on ne devrait
pas dépasser sont vraiment nos gardes
fous et en fait au delà de ses limites
il y a la mort la prison la peine on n'a
pas envie d'y aller vaut mieux pas et
d'un autre côté il y a justement ces
limites qu'on peut se permettre de
dépasser effectivement il y a une ligne
mais il y a quelque chose au-delà et on
peut se permettre d'aller voir ce qu'il
y a de l'autre côté ça peut nous plaire
ça peut ne pas nous plaire mais on peut
y aller et c'est là que c'est
intéressant
il faut oser
oser traverser la ligne
oser aller au-delà des limites et ça
c'est la chose la plus difficile et j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure parce que
selon moi c'est vraiment
indispensable au dépassement de soi
alors on va revenir sur cette fameuse
opercule de la barquette de beurre et en
fait je pense que tous ici depuis notre
naissance on est face à des limites qui
nous sont imposés par notre famille par
l'école par la société et finalement ces
limites deviennent notre cadre de vie
parce qu'à force qu'on nous les répète
qu'on nous rabâche les mêmes choses ça
devient vraiment notre notre façon de
vivre et puis on se pose plus vraiment
la question
et du coup moi quand j'étais petite on
avait des règles de vie à la maison
comme tout le monde qu'il fallait
respecter c'était les limites dans la
famille et là j'ai un exemple justement
très précis la fameuse barquette de
beurre qui est soit dit en passant très
futile mais qui pour moi a été une
véritable révélation donc quand j'étais
petit on me rabâcher systématiquement
quand j'utilisais le beurre qu'il
fallait remettre l'opercule sur le
beurre parce que sinon il allait jaunir
voilà c'est un truc qui m'enquiquiné
mais je le faisais parce que c'était une
règle parce que j'avais appris à faire
comme ça et je le faisais
systématiquement jusqu'à ce que ça
devienne vraiment une règle dans ma vie
d'adulte et quand j'ai eu 19 ans j'ai
quitté le nid familial je suis partie
vivre en colocation et pour la première
fois je me suis retrouvée face à des
interrogations et des gens qui me
demandaient mais si ça t'embête de le
faire pourquoi tu le fais pourquoi tu
remets sans arrêt cette opercule
et moi j'ai défendu le point de vue
parce que j'avais appris comme ça et
pour moi c'était normal j'ai défendu ça
pendant quelques semaines puis j'ai
attendu d'être toute seule un matin
avant de prendre mon petit déjeuner et
là du coup bah j'ai sorti mon beurre
j'allais me faire ma petite tartine
j'ai retiré l'opercule et je l'ai
regardé pendant une bonne minute je me
suis posé tout un tas de questions mais
pourquoi je fais ça
je me suis levé j'ai été juste à la
poubelle et j'étais jeté et là ça a été
une vraie révélation je me suis rendu
compte en fait quand j'étais face à ma
poubelle dans ma cuisine toute seule que
j'avais mon destin entre les mains que
je pouvais jouer avec les limites qu'on
m'avait fixées que je pouvais décider de
faire différemment et je peux vous dire
que ce petit déjeuner il a eu un goût
bien particulier le goût de la liberté
tout ça grâce à une opercule un opercule
d'ailleurs et en fait voilà ça a été
pour moi un grand moment je sais que ça
peut paraître totalement futile mais je
me suis rendu compte que j'avais le
pouvoir
ce que l'histoire ne dit pas c'est que
maintenant je remets l'opercule parce
que j'ai compris l'utilité de cette
petite chose mais comme je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure en fait l'important c'est
de savoir qu'on peut aller au-delà moi
j'ai été tâter le terrain de l'autre
côté ça m'a pas plu je suis revenue
mais j'y suis allé et c'est ça
l'essentiel je pense
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a peur d'aller
au-delà des limites les limites ont
quelque chose de très rassurant ça donne
un cadre ça permet de pas se poser de
questions en fait le confort de l'esprit
à l'intérieur des limites qu'on se fixe
ou qu'on fixe pour nous c'est familier
on sait comment ça marche on n'a pas à
se poser de questions et c'est rassurant
c'est très bien moi j'adore justement le
confort la sécurité le cadre c'est
quelque chose qui me plaît vraiment
alors pourquoi vouloir aller au-delà des
limites traverser cette ligne pour aller
sur ce terrain hostile si effrayant
pourquoi vouloir y aller
bah en fait
à chaque fois que j'ai traversé cette
fameuse ligne que j'étais au delà de mes
limites je me suis rendu compte que de
l'autre côté c'était assez incroyable et
à chaque fois que j'ai été au-delà de
mes limites je me suis rendu compte que
le monde avait encore plus de saveur
qui m'amène à vous raconter cette
première fois c'était pas l'opercule la
première fois où j'ai été au-delà de mes
limites j'avais 16 ans je vivais une
petite vie totalement tranquille normale
on va aller j'allais au collège tous les
jours j'avais très envie de voyager
j'avais beaucoup d'ambition comme tous
les jeunes de 16 ans et par contre
c'était quelque chose d'inimaginable on
avait de toute façon pas les moyens on
pourrait pas partir à l'autre bout du
monde et moi c'est ça qui me faisait
rêver partir à l'autre bout du monde et
j'ai eu justement
cette opportunité de partir en Australie
tout à coup j'avais la possibilité de
partir faire un échange linguistique de
trois mois toute seule en Australie et
en fait j'étais incapable de prendre la
décision je me suis retrouvé face à une
opportunité mais mes peurs elles m'ont
vraiment mis des barrières et je me suis
dit je vais laisser le destin décider je
vais remplir mon dossier je vais le
remettre si je suis prise c'est un signe
il faudra que j'y aille sinon ben c'est
que c'était pas pour moi
j'ai été prise et je suis donc partie en
Australie toute seule pendant trois mois
en arrivant là-bas malgré l'excitation
de me retrouver de l'autre côté de la
terre en fait j'ai vécu deux semaines
absolument horrible je me suis sentie
très seule j'étais dans un pays où je
maîtrisais ni la langue ni la culture
j'étais dans une famille d'accueil mais
on se comprenait pas avec ma
correspondante elle parlait pas français
je parlais pas anglais je savais
décliner les verbes être et avoir ça se
limitait à peu près à ça je comprenais
rien à ce que je lisais même les repères
naturels qu'on a dans la vie de tous les
jours les journaux les signes la
signalétique dans la rue enfin tout il y
a rien qui me parlait je comprenais pas
à la façon dont les gens vivaient parce
que culturellement c'était quand même
très différent
et là j'avais envie de rebrousser chemin
c'était un petit peu long de rentrer en
Suisse mais j'avais vraiment envie de
rentrer j'ai appelé mes parents et ils
ont essayé de me motiver
et ils m'ont dit
ils m'ont dit écoute Valentine je vous
évite l'accent on va les en parce que il
veut pas venir
Valentine tu as voulu partir maintenant
tu es là-bas tu restes là-bas hors de
question que tu rentres tu as quelque
chose à vivre là-bas c'est maintenant et
est-ce que tu vas vivre maintenant tu
pourras plus jamais le vivre donc essaie
de mettre tes peurs de côté ouvre-toi et
vas-y c'est maintenant
d'ailleurs je fais une petite parenthèse
je pense je pense enfin je suis certaine
maintenant que j'ai des enfants que mes
parents ont eu certainement eu besoin
d'aller au-delà de leur limite aussi
pour laisser partir leur fille de 16 ans
toute seule trois mois
en Australie moi je pense pas que je
serai capable de faire ça franchement
qu'elle courage vous y arriveriez c'est
quand même étonnant et j'ai trouvé ça
tellement bienveillant de leur part qui
laisse pas leur peur impacter ma liberté
mon choix ma vie ce que j'avais envie de
faire c'est un truc je pense que je leur
serais éternellement reconnaissante
et en effet les parents ont toujours
raison on le sait ils avaient raison
j'ai vraiment réussi à mettre toutes mes
peurs de côté j'ai une espèce de déclic
dans la tête et j'ai vraiment profité de
ces trois mois ça a été une expérience
absolument incroyable et à ce moment-là
en fait je me suis rendu compte que mon
monde n'avait plus aucune limite
quand j'ai eu 18 ans donc deux ans plus
tard j'ai perdu ma mère d'un cancer et
là mon monde qui n'avait plus de limite
tout à coup il s'est complètement
écroulé tous mes repères se sont
complètement ébranlés
et à ce moment là je sais pas si c'était
consciemment ou inconsciemment je me
suis imposé une limite je n'aurai jamais
d'enfant jamais
pour moi c'était impossible d'imaginer
avoir des enfants et à mon tour mourir
et les laisser je n'arrivais pas à
imaginer que la douleur que je
ressentais ben je puisse la transmettre
à mes enfants donc après ça ça a été
très facile très simple dans ma vie
sentimentale je savais que je ne
m'investirais pas que je n'aurais pas de
famille pas d'enfant voilà je vivais les
choses avec légèreté et ça m'allait très
bien le cadre que je m'étais reposé me
convenait parfaitement bien
jusqu'au jour où j'ai rencontré celui
qui allait devenir mon mari et à ce
moment-là en fait il a complètement
ébranlé mais mais convictions et mon
cadre qui me convenait très bien et il
est arrivé dans ma vie il m'a assommé
d'amour et tout à coup bah je me suis
retrouvé avec quelqu'un en face qui me
donnait envie de fonder quelque chose de
fonder une famille d'avoir des enfants
alors que jusque là c'était inimaginable
pour moi et et là c'était devenu plus
fort que ma raison
j'avais vraiment envie d'avoir des
enfants avec lui et aujourd'hui on a
deux enfants et c'était la prise de
risque la plus fantastique que j'ai
faite de toute ma vie parce que quand on
va au-delà de ses limites on prend des
risques et parfois au-delà des limites
ça peut être hyper excitant
alors je me suis demandé comment est-ce
que j'ai réussi à aller au-delà de mes
limites vous vous souvenez je vous ai
dit que oser c'était vraiment la chose
la plus importante je pense parce que
vouloir c'est une chose mais
oser c'est encore autre chose et comment
oser et bien je pense que la première
chose à faire c'est de se fixer des
objectifs
on se connaît vous savez comment vous
êtes vous connaissez vos peurs moi je
sais que je suis quelqu'un qui a peur
d'énormément de choses j'ai pas mal
d'anxiété et donc du coup je me fixe des
buts atteignables parce que plus ils
sont faciles à atteindre moi on a peur
par contre si on se lance des objectifs
fous là par contre ça peut faire très
très peur donc ça c'est vraiment à
chacun de jauger en fonction de de
comment il est et puis la qualité
essentielle à avoir c'est la confiance
en soi
la confiance en soi qui chez moi a
vraiment été révélé quand j'ai rencontré
mon mari et c'est vraiment lui qui a
révélé cette chose qui était totalement
inédite pour moi la confiance en moi et
ça va de pair avec justement un
entourage bienveillant et positif parce
que quand on a confiance en soi je pense
qu'on s'entoure des bonnes personnes et
quand on est entouré des bonnes
personnes ça booste notre confiance en
nous et moi il y a eu des fois où je
manquais vraiment cruellement de
confiance en moi et grâce à mon
entourage j'ai quand même réussi à
atteindre mes objectifs ils m'ont porté
ils m'ont boosté ils m'ont remonté le
moral alors certes ils peuvent pas faire
les choses à notre place mais ils
peuvent vraiment nous aider et
contribuer à notre succès ou en tout cas
contribuer à ce qu'on atteigne nos buts
voyager également comme ce premier
voyage que j'ai pu vivre à 16 ans
c'était juste incroyable c'est vrai que
en fait voyager ce qui est pratique avec
cette façon de faire pour
oser faire les choses c'est qu'on a pas
le choix on n'a pas de rigueur à
s'imposer quand on voyage de toute façon
ça vient à nous on va se retrouver
confronté à nos peurs on va se retrouver
à un moment donné où on est seul avec
nous-même donc ça va nous sortir malgré
nous de toute façon de notre zone de
confort et ça va nous aider à dépasser
nos limites et ça illustre bien le
proverbe les voyages forment la jeunesse
et j'aimerais terminer sur une
interrogation
une chose que j'avais envie de vous
demander je vous propose de prendre une
minute alors pas ce soir parce que on a
la fondue qui nous attend mais de
prendre une minute quand vous aurez le
temps de vous demander quels sont les
limites que vous avez envie de franchir
et de tout cœur je vous souhaite d'oser
merci
[Applaudissements]